hello everyone many a time in
engineering and science subjects there
are some students who feel that despite
putting in a lot of effort they still
end up getting low marks in this video I
wish to discuss some of the reasons
behind this share some tips with you so
that you can perhaps overcome this and
finally discuss what happens in the long
term in these kinds of situations so
first of all getting into the reasons
well there are some generic reasons like
the innate examination temperament the
innate ability to sit in an examination
Hall and perform well this is a question
of nerves and something which has to do
with perhaps a little bit of your own
physiological response to stress in a
very time-bounded fashion there is not
much that you can do to overcome this
kind of a natural uh Instinct so to
speak but we should not give up by
saying this okay there are a lot of
other factors involved and I wish to
discuss them in a little bit more detail
another reason is that
besides the examination temperament is
that uh you see
when we are talking about these kinds of
examinations especially at the
undergraduate level there is uh whether
you like it or not there is a bit of
history involved in every student's
academic trajectory meaning to say that
there is uh the question of how the
student's brain has evolved starting
from his or her school days uh how is
his or her
innate mathematical preparation because
in many of the cases this kind of a
situation arise in more of the problem
solving oriented kind of questions or
question papers again what has already
happened in your academic trajectory you
cannot do much about it of course you
can try to take some corrective measures
and we'll get into that now when we say
these kinds of genetic things it doesn't
really help you okay so beyond that okay
regarding your current status the
current things that you can do and
cannot do what what what are those so
are there any reasons
in that scenario well yes
so my first and foremost and perhaps the
most important point is that when you
are thinking that you are putting in a
lot of hard work try to see try to
introspect a lot uh whether that kind of
hard work is perhaps actually a bit of a
slog what I mean to say is that perhaps
you are doing uh I mean you are putting
a lot of physical effort you are solving
the problems again and again you are
trying to match with the answers uh
putting in a lot of time into solving
the problems as a result of all of this
effort like literally putting in the
tall and the tears in the sweat
but is this really hard work or is it
just slog
I I don't mean to Ruby rude here but
same uh if
for solving each and every one of the
problems maybe from some kind of a
problem sheet or a tutorial sheet or
maybe even from the
end of the chapter exercises from your
textbook for each of the each and every
one of the problems the root that you
are trying trying to take is somehow
apply the different kinds of formulas in
a hit and trial basis like a trial and
error basis and then trying to match
with the answers somehow without being
really sure about what you are doing in
each and every case so that is not
really hard work
okay you are just putting in the time
and effort to do
trial and error business
so what is really hard work so hard work
real hard work would be even before you
put pencil or pen to paper think long
and hard
very very hard think very hard about
what you have been asked to do what you
can do and think and and in what way you
can approach the problem so that at the
very first go you can arrive at the
correct answer because without this what
you are what you think you are putting
in is hard work is only like I mean I'm
sorry to say this but it is only like a
proof that you're not being able to
solve the problem at the first go so
time and again you are actually proving
to yourself that you are not being able
to do the problem at the first go so if
you're not able to do that do this in in
a situation where there is no time
pressure like when you're doing the
problem sheets then how do you expect
the things to go well
in an examination environment in an
examination Hall with the time pressure
that is never going to happen
okay so how do you overcome this so as I
said you have to really think hard and
long about the problem okay
maybe uh
after so so it can so happen that in in
the initial days you still do a little
bit of trial and error and somehow
manage to arrive at the answer
but after you have somehow managed to
arrive then said don't stop there and
move on to the next problem
slow down a little bit think why you
were thinking in the wrong direction in
the first place because without that
training of your mind you are not going
to be able to learn from your mistakes
and that is absolutely important okay I
cannot over emphasize this you have to
analyze the mistakes of your thinking
process after you have solved a problem
somehow after you have managed to get
the answer sometimes it can so happen
that that you have managed to get the
answer at the first go and you are
feeling very happy about it even then I
will suggest that you think a little bit
about the problem analyze about other
routes that you could have thought about
but accidentally you did not think about
you just happen to think about this
correct direction and and try to see for
yourself why those approaches other
approaches would be conceptually wrong
this is extremely extremely important
because when you train your mind to do
this
you will ah I mean your brain will be
prepared
from ah to to to avoid these kinds of
traps which sometimes the professor said
in the question papers okay of of making
the students think in the wrong
directions just because of some wording
in the problem or the way that the
problem is presented so this is
extremely important
in another case what happens is that
some there are some students who do
manage to think in the correct
directions without making any conceptual
mistakes but they have a tendency to go
into some kind of research mode whilst
doing the problems meaning that they'll
think in the right direction but while
solving the problems they'll think about
what could have happened if that was
that what could have happened about that
and and as a result in one problem
they'll spend maybe 45 minutes or 50
minutes now that is good at the research
level but you don't do that while
solving problems in an examination so if
that habit purses of not respecting the
time pressure when you uh so so that
will carry forward during the
examination Hollow in an examination
environment also so you will have to
develop that mental discipline of
postponing those kinds of interesting
and intellectual thing thoughts for
later attempts like if you're really
really wishing to do that first solve
the problem in a time-bounded fashion
this is my big tip to you so first solve
the problem like make a conscious effort
to solve the problem in the time-bounded
fashion and whatever thoughts you have
regarding the other directions that the
problem could have taken you postpone it
for later and as I said you you are you
you must allow yourself that that time
uh to to analyze the problem so do that
later postpone it for later but when you
are solving the problems think in the
right direction and do it in a very
time-bounded fashion as if you are
sitting for an examination
and the thing is that unlike your
coaching institutes where you you sat
for many many mock tests here there is
nobody to give you mock test in an
engineering or or a science uh class
okay so if you are all alone so you have
to give yourself a like a situation of a
mock test by yourself okay there'll be
no mock test Okay the third reason is uh
sometimes the students do not end up
performing well because
uh what happens is that they they are
very consistent in their studies they
study all throughout the semester maybe
but what happens is that in each of the
chapters their knowledge is at a very
shallow level they don't go into the
in-depth uh I mean the nooks and
crannies the nuts and bolts
um which on which points the professor
sometimes tells the students so in each
and every chapter if your knowledge is
not too much in depth it's not like it's
not penetrating into the hurt and soul
of the situation then in the examination
hall or in the examination situation
where in the question question paper
from each and every chapter there will
be a little bit of a challenge so maybe
you will be able to solve the problems
partially with your shallow knowledge
but you will be you will not be able to
solve any of the problems completely
because of the shallowness of your
knowledge so I mean ah one strategy
could be that if you are finding it
short on time uh
then
don't go into don't try to go into too
much depth in all the chapters but at
least whatever chapters you study go
into proper detail and depth into that
try to really really understand the hurt
and soul of the concepts okay
shallowness in the knowledge is
ultimately not going to help you next
let us discuss the long term situation
so what happens in these kinds of
situations when where students are
putting in the effort but time and again
they're getting low marks so we have
broadly identified two categories of
students of some the first category
being where there is a an incorrect
method of preparing from the problem
sheets and thinking about the problems
and the other one is that where there is
a certain slowness
embedded in the in this problem solving
strategy so my point is that you should
not be feeling despondent or depressed
by these discussions okay rather you
should take a heard from these
discussions
in ah in identifying that yes so this is
the problem that you have and this can
actually be corrected all that you have
to do is change your habits a little bit
and mind you and this if you're at the
second year third year level even at the
fourth year level it is not too late
Okay so
uh I mean people change their habits so
late in life why can't you you are I
mean in the in the broad scheme of
things in the academic life you are
still children
ok so
take heart from that now I I want to
emphasize on two points regarding the
long term things
first and foremost
you may be thinking that oh I am doing
hard work but this is of no use uh let
me give up on that please do not your
innate ability to do hard work is like a
superpower that you have do not give up
on that
okay
see if you can correct your methods if
you can correct the way of preparation
the correct the way of studying then
combine with combined if you combine
your superpower of hard work which you
actually have okay so so that that tall
and tears uh so if you can combine that
with the correct method of studying you
will yourself be surprised by how much
improvement it will bring about
next uh next point is that it is quite
natural that you may feel a little bit
envious your After All Flesh and Blood
to see that some students who are
apparently not putting in the hard work
getting much more marks than you who are
outperforming you it is very natural
so again do not lose hurt
the first thing to note here is that
even though it may seem that some of
them are not putting the hard work but
in reality some of them are actually
putting in the hard work in the sense
that how much penetrative thoughts they
are putting in in the little time that
they are studying and the other thing is
that there are actually situations and I
know this where some students do manage
to get very good marks despite not
putting in the hard work as you may
think
but remember this
at the very first years of study they
may get by they may Coast uh by not
putting in the hard work but there will
come a transition time where no amount
of talent no amount of natural ability
can substitute for hard work
okay this is not something theoretical I
am saying I have seen this from my own
case from my friends cases from now that
I have become a faculty member I've seen
the students cases also over the years
there is only there's only up to certain
stage in academics that you can progress
without the hard work okay based only on
Talent
after that it is absolutely absolutely
necessary so that superpower of hard
work that you have if you preserve that
it will it will bring you the benefits
in the long term
okay so please do not give up on that
superpower that init superpower that you
have okay in the advanced stages of
academics in the higher years of study
it will be absolutely absolutely
essential so on this positive note I
will end this video all the very best on
correcting your methods uh and on
performing well so much that you will be
actually Satisfied by the consistency
between the effort that you put in and
the results that you get all the very
best thank you